we have some things in common first of
all I know we share a birthday because
every year I'll be on my birthday it's
an it's one of the kind of weird things
that happens if you're a public person
they'll say like and today you know
Conan O'Brien is and they'll say how old
I am and I'm always like I don't tell
them that and then but but you and I the
same April 18 yeah it's a cool birthday
to happen I like it I like it
yeah I like to put it out there so that
I get guests coming up we have something
else in common which is we are both part
of big families I think we both are from
families of six kids six kids yeah me
too that's crazy
where were you in the birth order to be
youngest you're the number six right
yeah I don't even know where I fall yeah
where everyone's pretty tall yeah for
the most part but I would say yeah I was
third so I was the one that was like
well anyone pay attention to me I'll get
a show someday I said that a lot I was
last and also the smallest one and like
you know I mean it's no wonder that I
became an actor I just I had to like
sing and dance so people would like
remember to feed me I'm like I'm here to
write did you did you get to were there
a lot of strict rules in your house bro
oh yeah yeah yes and no it was like
strict rules but also chaos all the time
just chaos and we were like raised by
the television like single mom working
mom we were latchkey so you were allowed
to watch TV oh goodness yes like the TV
was like the thing yeah yeah in our
house we were not allowed to watch TV
during the week but we would mm-hmm but
we knew it my father my father's car
sounded like it made like kind of a
whistling sound cause his old car and
we'd well be watching TV and we'd hear
this whistling come up the road of his
weird pontiac 1970 Bonneville and we
would be like God and we would turn off
the TV
grab books most of them upside down
because we were faking it and then he
would come rushing into the house and he
would feel the screen and if it was warm
he'd be like I've done all of you
it was a terrible way to live very sad
childhood but I wanted you to know that
thank you but what are you gonna do
you're gonna have nowadays people are so
careful about screen time you're gonna
have kids are you gonna be really
careful about that
I think I'm overreacting because I grew
up with so much screen time and I was
like raised by the television that I'd
like I just you know I always think of
like oh my god the hours that I spent
sitting in front of the television but
like TV you know I mean it did me some
good like I have a career now and maybe
it you know so you think you you it
helped you I don't I don't think the TV
I got to help me be on TV in any way
that was time I could have been curing
cancer I just watch TV said you know
everything about Green Acres yeah yeah
yeah a reference nobody got